[Music]
in rotten roommate news submitted by
slam poetry hmm have you guys ever been
to one of those yes I have so
interesting it was very hard spoken word
yeah I liked about one out of like 20
they used the same rhyme scheme yeah
it's because I I mean it's always some
struggle stuff I want to see some I want
to see here's some funny stuff yeah get
in it
Def Jam poetry is [ __ ] dope um a
student is being charged after bragging
about the sick things she did to sobota
ch her roommate sabotage sabotage it's a
voltage why did she so sue I asked the
question and then I realized that was
real bars and not being a good cast
member she need to be asking questions
like thank you good somebody took out
your batteries dude I caught myself that
analytical psychic analytical bar mother
[ __ ] started all right so two freshmen
students at the University of Hartford
in Connecticut
they've been having issues being
roommates they were randomly assigned
being roommates right so Chanel rohui
AKA AKA jazzy okay that's all related
I'm so in to say she already sounds like
she doesn't go to coach Bobby has like
really good jazz hands
so jazzy posted a 103 minute Facebook
live video describing her roommate
nightmare and so she said that she had
felt unwelcome in her own room so she
started the semester she had been she
had been experiencing throat pain for
weeks all dr. holder that she had a
bacterial infection then I thought she's
gonna rape that notice that's what I
thought - I thought she
my mind just went to oh she's putting
some [ __ ] in her water or something oh I
thought she was getting like throat
[ __ ] or something at night and if she
slept through the whole thing that's
what I thought too Geo these guys are
crazy nice no not alone much porn
bacteria whatever that's like sore
throat right throat pain is like yeah
cuz she didn't say I have a sore throat
I have throat pain wait but a sore
throat is the pimples no it's like when
someone goes oh I'm sorry
it's sore and hurting or it's different
you know throw pain its it hurts sore
throat is it's sore oh yeah
throat pain is how you got popped in the
[ __ ] mouth with like the end of a
tunnel right all right you guys
understand English okay yeah she chose
the wrong words yeah always
all right David and cheated all right
another student alerted her Jazze of
social media posts that showed her
roommate Brianna admitting to [ __ ]
with her so this is jazzy and she's in
the jumpsuit was jazzy this one okay
this is Brianna jazzy is my speculation
correct yeah I was right yep my last
Chanel
99% chance I'll guess that right yeah
yeah so then this is a post that Brianna
she posted the caption says finally did
it yo girl got rid of her roommate after
one and a half month of spitting in her
coconut oil putting moldy clam dip in
her lotions rubbing used tampons on her
backpack putting her toothbrush in
places where the Sun don't shine Oh what
film a day more I can finally say
goodbye to Jamaican Barbie well she was
trying to get rid of lecture
it's racial Brianna was trying to get
rid of Chanel and so now that's chemical
warfare now Briana's been arrested and
she's charged with third degree criminal
mischief and second degree breach of
peace and she could also face charges of
a hate crime yeah hate crime breach of
peace I never heard of that crime that's
such a dope [ __ ] way to phrase like
yes every time you farts
breathe preacher priest preacher
preacher Reese I'll take that over
chemical warfare any day because the
sentence were chemical warfare is way
yeah you know what people do in jail
they take a poopoo in the cup wait for
that [ __ ] to get all rotten and
[ __ ] and then they create Spears and a
dip that [ __ ] like a poisonous arrow and
then they shoot at the guards chemical
warfare they try to poison your ass hey
man people in prison did they got
definite got a lot of time on their
hands and you're pretty creative
I don't know human feces did that I
thought I just kind of got wiped away
died I don't know about that I don't
think I could ever hate a guard enough
to sleep next to [ __ ] yeah I mean human
[ __ ] is like pungent I think it's pigeon
[ __ ] I mean I think it's cuz you're
sleeping this [ __ ] anyways you have that
metal toilet right with no water oh
there's no I don't think it's a flush is
the way it is ours does man I just see
this is just don't go to prison man that
shit's crazy dude it is crazy watched
enough TV to know is this girl gonna go
to prison uh well so now she's been
kicked out of the school of course a bit
88 yeah and the case is being
transferred to the Superior Court
so she released a statement or anything
and I'm curious as to what she said
after my knowledge I'm glad she was
stupid enough to brag about it
self-incrimination have you guys ever
been RA before no no but my RA was
really hot it's like you know when you
have the college dorms oh yeah and they
had the the hallway right like they kind
of check in on everyone yeah cuz I was
wondering like how many stories and how
many like issues do they hear and like
how many times like it sounds like it
could have been so easy for them to play
yoke and we kind of like
they tried and they're like you got a
stuck yeah you know I hope Jesse should
know what's her name
Chanel jazzy the third is going desi
okay I hope Jenelle I'm sorry what's her
name
jazzy got to happy I hope jaundice right
I hope she becomes like a [ __ ] doctor
or some [ __ ] and then she [ __ ] excels
to the highest level of like education
and you [ __ ] you like that that's the
best type of revenge too she's gonna
because she's still stayed in school and
the other girl got kicked out like a
[ __ ] little bit I'm saying dude she
look like she got a [ __ ] smart head
on her [ __ ] shoulders you guys don't
know what if jazzy was a bad room and I
was thinking - OH
jazzy was saying that she like brie and
would just like smile and like fake it
she had no idea that she was doing all
this SH because she's a conniving as
passive as [ __ ] passive aggressive
likes she's a [ __ ] spy that's what
she is a Russian spy coming out here to
[ __ ] conspire against us Americans
I'm not with you anymore I was with you
all right all right maybe she was maybe
jazzy is like bury me bury like and I'm
not saying this because she brat okay so
I'm just say it out straight up
she's probably mean or whatever I don't
know and then [ __ ] what's-her-name
Brianna Brianna was like well I'm too
scared to confront her ass so let me
[ __ ] try to get rid of her like in a
different way that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] but
it could happen it does happen a lot -
actually when I live in Riverside I had
a roommate who did not clean up his [ __ ]
whatsoever why did a Rochelle like to
the mat like plates and stuff like
plates chicken bones whatever it doesn't
[ __ ] matter because he was so used to
his parents or his parent his mom taking
care of him he just would never do it
I'm talking about this [ __ ]
said it wasn't his [ __ ] what his name's
was on his plate
it literally said Darrell he was like
that's not my stuff and you know it's to
that point when somebody says that
they're just trying to [ __ ] egg you
want you know so for me is asking for
ass beating yeah so I was trying to be a
really polite in the in the best way
that I could which is you know
confronting like oh man god clean up
your [ __ ] you know what I mean and then
he just continually
do it long story short I took all of his
plates out and I threw it on the middle
of the floor and on the [ __ ] dining
table so he could see it when he when he
got out
so when to this [ __ ] party came back
the [ __ ] still didn't clean his
[ __ ] is so [ __ ] angry it literally
kicked out his [ __ ] door and then you
know like those dorm desks are super
[ __ ] cheap and I [ __ ] put my fist
to it Wow just [ __ ] angry as I clean
up your [ __ ] [ __ ] and I went into my
room and I started complaining to my
roommate about it and it was Tony and
everybody was just so passive-aggressive
and they were all upset but nobody said
anything yeah you know what I mean I had
a roommate like that too
and the next day guess what happened
this [ __ ] was mr. clean the
whole room was vacuumed out he cleaned
up the whole [ __ ] and then he went to
the other roommates to tell them that yo
I think David overreacted I was I didn't
[ __ ] overreact nobody was on his side
at that point it just because they
wouldn't confront him you know anybody
got so the reason why I kicked down his
door was because I was like Darrell
clean up your [ __ ] and he did it [ __ ] it
okay I know that though you're a curious
you know what to get pissed and you're
like oh there's a door there's a side of
you that's like I am pissed but it's
also the side to like cannot break it
but you know what can I kick through it
you know what pissed me off though so he
didn't say anything so I was like oh
this [ __ ] should sleep but I'm
gonna talk to him in the morning and
then I hear a guitar string only one
other person in the apartment has a
guitar and his [ __ ] Darrell so he was
awake and he completely ignored me and
that's why I kicked the door down so so
[ __ ] mad you know but that's that
type of chef talk about you could have
very bad roommates College is an
interesting time because I feel like
that's the first time most people
encounter with enclosed spaces and in
long durations of time of like cabin
fever yeah - the situation - yeah yeah
exactly and it's like that's when you
figure out like can you handle that kind
of pressure of like telling someone to
do their [ __ ] I think it's a really good
experience because the other other night
you live in your own comfort zone and
then so you're living with family or
whatever but then being thrown
experience or it's a bunch of strangers
you guys have to coexist I think that's
pretty cool it's like a lot of growth
you can get from there yeah because like
even like the whereas
because I grew up with the brother yeah
I mean my mom's very clean so I'm like
used to having a clean place and it's
not like I came up to Matt aggressive
yeah I mean as a bro remembered like to
clean up your dishes man because we need
because first of all there's like five
people living in the apartment so that's
five dishes that come out for breakfast
let you know what I mean so you have to
clean your stuff or the sinks gonna be
full of big-ass apartment it was a dorm
apartment though Oh true there was there
was um actually there was more than that
cuz me and Tony were in one room and
them young and young and Daryl were in a
room and then there was Christian and
then there was Scott oh okay so it was
like the normal apartment yeah so it was
like that type of situation so if one
person doesn't clean the dish and
everybody doesn't clean a dish it fills
up in like an hour and it builds
momentum because someone sees one plate
or a [ __ ] I don't put my play the band
exactly and I was like super cordial
there's so many stories like this about
people having issues in their dorms but
there are a or weather wherever don't
let them move and because it's too much
[ __ ] work and I bet there's so much
drama that's constantly going down with
like fresh new students that's never
lived with other people and all that
[ __ ] they probably just forced you to
like get along it sucks because like I
think like if I had a little more
empathy back then I would have
understood that number one he was he
liked it he's an only child and he has a
mom that almost took care of him but I
couldn't see I'm just so enraged you
know I mean so I didn't know how to talk
to him that was my [ __ ] room a duffel
smell like cheese all day mama's boy and
when I forced that [ __ ] to move out
his mom came and [ __ ] helped to move
everything you're in your mid-20s you
[ __ ] damn dude the Enabling ass [ __ ]
you mid-20s [ __ ] yeah dude I don't know
I was kind of jealous of how much you
was spoiled oh you're like I want to be
spoiling ya
[Music]